thanks guys ad first how's the ankle you
tweaked her early in the game but your
feelings up so strong it'll be all right
it'll be all right it'll be all right
when you heard LeBron wasn't playing
tonight did you feel you had to do more
tonight not having LeBron um I think not
just me but everybody uh and it show TP
shot the ball very well something you
know about uh Austin played well DLo C
Wood ruy everybody had to step up I mean
when you missing a guy like that
offensive presence defensive presence
leadership everybody has to raise their
game you know not just me but uh
obviously know he's not playing I got to
take majority of the of the of the
workload and you know I was ready for it
tonight that last break you went over to
GA and Chan you were talking about women
Yama your competitive Spirit came out
tonight take me through that competitive
nature yeah man I know he can play um
you know obviously there's a lot of
pressure on him number one pick uh but
he can play you know he been struggling
a little bit but he showed up tonight I
think he had 30 um it's some two big
threes uh a couple highlight plays some
tip dunks and things like that some good
blocks but uh he's one of them ones you
know generational Talent um it was fun
going against him tonight all right
defensively we know you're going to do
what you do but since the championship
game is play in tournament you on one
now offensively take me through how you
feeling feeling good uh jump shot
feeling real good now um you know
finishing just being more locked in know
where we trying to go uh you know lot of
people just say you know you just need
one of those games and that championship
game was that game for me um to get back
on the on how I am how I'm used to
playing how every used to seeing me play
so I just got to keep it going keep
getting wins appreciate you big fell ad
guys brought his a game
tonight and I hit two threes tonight for
you there you go baby he was leaving it
yes
[Applause]
sir